[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 30 juin
depuis mars dernier une colocation de
bus personnes atteintes de la maladie
d'alzheimer a ouvert ses portes aux
loges en josas c'est la deuxième maison
de ce genre dans les yvelines
nous irons sur place rencontrer les
colocataires et sur cette thématique de
la maladie d'alzheimer
notre invité à ce sujet nathalie bouaziz
chef de service au centre d'accueil de
jour la porte verte à versailles nous
parlerons sport également les jeux
olympiques de tokyo sont programmées
dans trois semaines plusieurs événements
avons participé à ce rendez vous
planétaire du 23 juillet au 8 août tour
d'horizon direction montigny le
bretonneux ensuite le centre aquatique
du lac a organisé une journée découverte
de ses activités ce mercredi 30 juin
au programme hammam jacuzzi ou encore
aquagym une première pour le centre
aquatique est aussi découverte de
l'hippodrome de rambouillet comme je
vous le disais en titre une colocation
pour personnes atteintes de la maladie
d'alzheimer vient d'ouvrir ses portes
aux loges en josas
un concept original pour déstigmatiser
la maladie c'est la deuxième du genre
dans les yvelines
reportage avec juillet prigent
c'est souvent elizabeth qui pousse la
chansonnette au 9 rue de but qu elle vit
tout comme sept autres personnes en
colocation une coloc un peu particulière
tous sont atteints de la maladie
d'alzheimer
je pense que mes enfants mangent et un
châle tour je l'aurais m'a amené ici
parce que je préfère être chez moi
honnêtement mais pour tout dire j'ai le
petit à petit j'ai compris que dans
cette maison j'avais des relations de m
les affaires communes avec d'autres
personnes et que rester seul dans mon
appartement que ce n'était pas une
bonne solution mais j'avais déjà mis à
proximité c'est que c'est un art nouveau
de la personnalité je le sais d'autant
plus vous voulez que je crée mois des
résidences médicalisées
ici c'est pas une résidence médicalisée
c'est une résidence tout court ces
personnes âgées profitent d'un concept
particulier nommé la maison des sages
est fondée par lisa l'immobilier
solidaire et associatif ouverte en mars
dernier aux loges en josas c'est la
deuxième maison du genre dans les
yvelines
on part du principe qu'une petite
communauté de vie dans une maison
ordinaire permet de déstigmatiser la
maladie et de ce centre est plutôt sur
la personne et de permettre plus tôt
quand on n'est pas d'avoir un gros
collectif 200 personnes de 80 ou 100
personnes ou isolement et la sécurité du
domicile de trouver un bon compromis
entre la personne seule ou le
l'établissement en permettant
d'accompagner les personnes à leur
rythme
350 m² rénover un ascenseur créé jardin
cuisine ou encore salon salle à manger
sont partagés mais les chambres elles
sont complètement individualisé pour un
coût entre 2500 et 3500 euros
c'est vrai que colocation en france un
pas très bonne réputation et puis on
pense surtout aux étudiants qu'on est
comme chez soi avec un service
d'accompagnement qui sécurise qui
rassure à la fois le malades et les
aidants et qui permet aussi d'avoir des
activités comme une vie ordinaire une
vie ordinaire avec quelques règles
toutefois la journée est rythmée
toilettes soit un temps de pause entre
coupé de moments obligatoire les repas
en communauté
[Musique]
c'est pas parce qu'on est vieux qu'on
doit attendre de mourir en fait on a le
droit de vivre encore et de voilà de
danser de chanter de faire la cuisine
est en fait cette stimulation par
rapport à la maladie d'alzheimer
il a ses troubles de mémoire ils sont en
fait des personnes si elles sont dans un
cadre rassurant et protecteur
elles sont treize à l accueil beaucoup
la stimulation des activités sont aussi
proposés aux colocataires jeux de
société couture ou encore cuisine une
colocation somme toute classique
un peu comme en famille maladie la
maladie d'alzheimer
nous accueillons nathalie bouaziz
bonsoir vous êtes chef de sa vie je sais
pas si vous m'entendez nathalie bouaziz
alors j'espère que vous allez nous
entendre un instant je le dis vous êtes
chef de service au sein du centre
d'accueil de jour la porte verte de
versailles alors est-ce que la thalie
bouaziz vous m'entendez oui bonsoir 20
soit vous êtes avec nous c'est pareil
rendez-vous vous m'entendez oui très
bien avant de parler votre activité
justement et de votre centre d'accueil
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce concept
de colocation pour personnes atteintes
de la maladie d'alzheimer convient de
voir dans le reportage
alors nous avons des petits soucis de
connexion avec vous-même bouaziz
moi je pense qu'il ya une très bonne
alternative des petits soucis de
connexion c'est bon je vous entends
alors à la fin mars
et voilà le concept j'ai entendu la
question donc tout va bien
je pense que c'est un concept
intéressant c'est une bonne alternative
à la fois à la haute aux missiles et à
l'est pas parce que ça permet aux
personnes de vivre dans un lieu de vie
commun tout en gardant leurs habitudes
de tisser des liens sociaux à petite
échelle c'est vraiment un lieu de vie
humaniser et qui permet un
accompagnement individualisé et
singulier de chacun alors je le rappelle
vous êtes chef de service ou sommes en
accueil de jour qui se situe à
versailles qu'est ce qu'un accueil de
jour en particulier alors un accueil de
jour 6 une structure qui accueille à la
journée des personnes atteintes de
maladies neuro évolutif qui vivent à
leur domicile
c'est un lieu où ces personnes peuvent
venir passer une à deux journées par
semaine pour faire des activités de
stimulation de loisirs mais aussi avant
tout pour retrouver une vie sociale ce
qui est quelque chose de très important
surtout face à la crise sanitaire que
nous traversons actuellement
alors vous accueillez donc également
j'imagine des personnes atteintes de la
maladie d'alzheimer qu'elles sont des
activités qui sont proposées à 7 ce type
de personne qui est attendu cette
maladie alors nous proposons à la fois
des activités de la vie quotidienne
m comme mettre la table installée et le
matériel rangé mais aussi des activités
des jeux de fluence verbale pour
travailler tout ce qui est autour du
vocabulaire et puis des activités
manuelles du jardinage du chant beaucoup
de en fait beaucoup d'activités en
fonction des centres d'intérêt et des
capacités des personnes qu'est ce que ça
leur rapporte qu est ce que ça leur
rapporte pardon à ces personnes
justement ces activités le fait d'aller
en accueil de jour une à deux fois par
semaine
le fait d'aller en actes et en accueil
de jour déjà ça permet aux personnes de
rythme et leur semaine de retrouver une
vie sociale à l'extérieur de la maison
pouvoir passer du temps avec d'autres de
se resocialiser août préserver le lien
social
ça leur permet aussi par le biais
d'activités adaptées à leurs capacités
de retrouver une estime d'elle-même et
ça c'est extrêmement important dans la
maladie
ça leur permet aussi de se mettre en
situation de réussite puisque l'équipe
demande aux personnes de réaliser des
activités qu'elles soient en capacité de
faire comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure alors vous l'avez évoqué pour le
confinement cette crise sanitaire qu'on
connaît bien maintenant comment ça s'est
passé justement dans votre centre
d'accueil de jour
alors chez nous il ya eu deux phases de
confinement tout d'abord le confinement
strict comme comme nous avons tous connu
où l'équipe s'est attaché à préserver
justement le lien avec l'ensemble des
personnes accueillies dans notre
structure et leurs aidants donc en
proposant des activités quotidiennes à
chacun par le biais d'internet par le
téléphone aussi et de d'entretenir des
entretiens téléphoniques et des
relations par mail également ensuite
nous avons la chance de réouvrir très
très rapidement après le déconfinement
tout début juin 2020 et depuis nous
n'avons jamais fermé
donc quand nous avons pris des mesures
évidemment très strictes et est
contraignante pour tout le monde mais
qui nous ont permis de maintenir la
structure ouverte depuis maintenant un
peu plus d'un an et nous nous en
réjouissons pour pour les personnes que
nous accueillons deux dernières
questions très rapidement est-ce que
vous avez vu une différence sur les
personnes que vous accueillez au
quotidien dans votre centre d'accueil de
jour
est-ce que vous avez vu une différence
avec cette crise n y faire escale à
peser sur ces personnes atteintes de la
maladie d'alzheimer en particulier
alors je dirais qu'elle a
essentiellement peser sur l'entourage
sur leurs proches aidants qui en prit
pour certains conscience de l'évolution
de la pathologie de leurs proches pour
les personnes qui viennent chez nous
mais aussi pour l'or pour leurs proches
l'isolement-- était un poids vraiment
important et je dirais que nous en
faisons maintenant les frais aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'on s'en est pas rendu
compte tout de suite au départ
[Musique]
et personne sont revenus plutôt humble
cette crise a fait des dégâts merci en
tout cas à taëz ibb oasis pour toutes
ces précisions et d'avoir été avec mr
cette édition merci à vous merci à vous
à revoir dans le reste de l'actualité et
sébastien premier alors président de
l'association nationale médias handicap
la nmhh a été fait le 24 juin dernier
chevalier de l'ordre national du mérite
une récompense pour ses 17 ans de
bénévolat au service de ses champions de
la vie comme il les appelle son
association organise des interviews de
personnalités médiatiques pour des
personnes handicapées et aussi des
actions de sensibilisation objectif
faire évoluer l'image de la personne
handicapée dans la société et dans les
médias le tout nouveau chevalier de
l'ordre national du mérite a été
félicité par de nombreuses personnes et
personnalités
regardez mars et porto tu fais pas on
verra europe et partout dans la province
et les ter habitants salut mon seb
je sais à quel point ce moment est
vitale essentielle pour toi c'est
tellement oui nécessaire que tu soit
reconnue et récompensée pour ton
engagement toit était champion de la vie
donc de tout coeur avec toi tu le sais
comme d'habitude même si je ne peux pas
être avec toi
physiquement je suis avec l'esprit avec
le coeur et de toutes mes forces
tous mes voeux de bonheur et ton soutien
à média handicap champions pour la vie
ensemble sur la ligne même ligne de
départ
voilà je vous embrasse très très fort
mes pensées avec vous aujourd'hui
dubai un petit mot pour dire un grand
bravo à tous les interviewer en herbe de
l'association média handicap et je parle
de celle de thibault de josé de
jean-claude bravo à vous et j'encourage
évidemment tout le monde à aller like et
la page de deux médias handicap qui
montre bien que rien est impossible et
direction montigny le bretonneux à
présent le centre aquatique du lac
proposé ce mercredi 30 juin une journée
découverte de ses différentes activités
cours collectifs de fitness à quoi j ou
encore hammam et jacuzzi
les personnes intéressées pouvaient
s'inscrire à 3 créneau gratuitement
c'est la première fois que le centre
organisait cette journée
le reportage bas street vers vers
retrouver ou découvrir le centre
aquatique du lac à montigny le
bretonneux
ce mercredi 30 juin la municipalité et
celle de voisins-le-bretonneux organisé
une journée spéciale les habitants
étaient invités à tester trois activités
proposées par le centre et ce
gratuitement
ça fait partie de ces équipements qui
ont été fermées ces nombreux maux
derniers mois ou ré ouvert de façon très
épisodique
donc on a voulu attirer à nouveau nos
usagers qu'ils viennent s'approprier
nouveau l'espace et voir un petit peu ce
qu'on peut leur proposer tant sur le
niveau aquatiques que sur le fitness ou
encore sur la partie où elle laisse le
centre propose de nombreuses activités
même les habitués profite de cette
journée pour découvrir de nouveaux
loisirs
je trouve ça super ça permet de
découvrir l'établissement pour les
personnes qui ne connaissent pas et de
tester des activités je viens les
piscines pratiquement tous les jours
j'ai un abonnement annuel
alors je fais surtout d agréer des
instruments et du vélo le centre dispose
d'une salle de musculation et d'une
autre dédiée au cardio et la crise
sanitaire a eu
un impact sur la pratique des usagers je
pense que la crise a permis aux gens se
rendent compte que qui peuvent faire
beaucoup de choses tout seul à la maison
donc le groupe training et s'est
beaucoup démocratisé
après à côté de ça il ya aussi ils sont
aussi rendus compte du besoin en fait
d'être en fait d'être accompagnés dans
leurs pratiques et le besoin de se
dépenser
les abonnements pour le centre sont
disponibles au mois au trimestre ou à
l'année
les habitants de montigny voisins le
bretonneux peuvent profiter d'un tarif
préférentiel
parlons sport à présent les jeux
olympiques de tokyo sont programmées
d'ici trois semaines
plusieurs événements avons participé à
ce rendez vous planétaire du 23 juillet
au 8 août
tour d'horizon avec michael lynne
d'euros cet été les yvelines seront bien
représentés pendant ces jeux olympiques
de tokyo le contingent évinois devrait
être composée d'une dizaine de sportifs
parmi eux trois triathlètes du club de
poissy seront de la partie
dorian coninx cassante beaugrand et
léonie périodes cette dernière connaîtra
ses premiers jo
c'est un honneur de représenter kouassi
parce qu'on ait fait pas je les côtoie
depuis hier
depuis je pense 2010 par là donc c'est
vraiment bas c'était le but et on a
réussi en golf antoine ros nord du golfe
de la boulie à versailles représentera
la france sur cette compétition après
une année 2009 un teint de haut niveau
une victoire au qatar masters
à 28 ans le sportif espère remporter une
médaille en aviron la rameuse claire
beauvais de l'association sportive
mantaise fait partie des favoris dans
son sport pour un podium cet été un
podium ce serait franchement c'est un
beau rêve là les armes pour se battre
dans la catégorie et pour faire de
belles choses donc c'est un beau rêve
mais
un petit peu réaliste quand même un
cyclisme sur piste ils seront plusieurs
à partir au japon la fédération
française a décidé de miser sur la
jeunesse avec 4 pépite mathilde de gros
21 ans sébastien vie j'ai 24 ans ryan el
al 22 ans et florian gringo 20 ans
licencié au vc sky qui vous sert le réel
objectif
une carrière sportive de haut niveau qui
est la médaille aux jeux olympiques donc
très content mais il ya encore beaucoup
de travail et on va chercher la plus
belle des médailles en bmx cinq sportifs
qui s'entraînent sur le stadium à côté
du vélodrome nationale vont s'envoler
pour les jeux on retrouve dans la
sélection manon valentino axel etienne
silva andré le triple champion du monde
joris daudet ou encore romain mahieu je
pense que pour chaque sportif de haut
niveau participe aux jeux olympiques
c'est c'est le plus gros objectif d'une
carrière donc super content ça va juste
la première étape
maintenant on va y aller pour une
médaille ce qui esquive l'atelier le
rêve est et pourquoi on travaille tous
les jours
en judo à 34 ans guillaume chaîne
participera à ses premiers jeux
olympiques après avoir été remplaçant en
2016 à rio
judoka espère faire briller son club de
sartrouville au niveau international
dans la catégorie des moins de 73 kg
l'objectif comme chacun des athlètes qui
se présente aux jeux olympiques
j'espère pour eux c'est d'aller
décrocher l'or maintenant moi c'est mes
premiers jeux olympiques donc
c'est déjà une petite victoire en soit
maintenant j'y mets pas pour figurer non
plus en boxe maiva hamadouche a réussi à
se qualifier pour les jeux olympiques la
sportive du boxing club saint quentin en
yvelines sera dans la catégorie des
moins de 60 kg une grande première pour
cette boxeuse passé professionnel en
2013 c'est un rêve surtout qu'en étant
cox aux professionnels
j'avais vraiment laissé les jeux
olympique de côté parce que savoir quand
on est sportif
quand on est boursière professionnels on
n'a pas le droit de se présenter aux
jeux olympiques ça s'est ouvert pour les
en gros à rio la sévère la semaine pour
les femmes également la porte au kiosque
un très chaud ces jo sur les légions
tout simplement
donc en fait pour moi c'est une chance
inestimable
enfin en bas le versailles et valentin
porte devrait faire partie de l'équipe
de france à tokyo champion du monde avec
les experts en 2015 et 2017
l'arrière droit espère remporter cette
fois ci un titre olympique avec la
sélection tricolore
ces événements vont ils tous performer à
tokyo réponse à partir du 23 juillet
pour refermer cette édition la ville de
rambouillet abrite en bordure de sa
forêt l'un des plus grands hippodromes
d'île de france datant de la fin du 19e
siècle
coup de projecteur avec michael aline
d'euros au coeur de la forêt de
rambouillet sur un site de 40 hectares
depuis plus d'un siècle les passionnés
de courses hippiques peuvent assister à
des manifestations sur cet hippodrome
historique du a organisé ses premières
courses en 1890 avec des tribunes en
bois autour de la piste
c'était si vous voulez des courses
familial et amical
y'avait pas du tout dangereux comme on a
aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui on allait
on a les jeux qui sont faits sur
l'hippodrome à l'époque c'était plutôt
des ce qu'on appelle des courses de jean
thomann c'étaient des amis qui se
rencontraient et qui courait après des
décennies de courses l'hippodrome est
devenu un lieu réservé aux
professionnels le site organise neuf
réunions chaque année entre avril et
octobre
depuis 1991 l'hippodrome se consacre
uniquement à la spécialité du trot les
passer en première catégorie en janvier
ça veut dire qu'on a des si vous voulez
des écuries des grandes écuries qui vont
à vincennes et ailleurs vienne courait
aussi et on a des gains plus importants
des courses là maintenant on a vraiment
les deux rives heures qui viennent
dériveurs de paris qui viennent courir
en vie l'hippodrome est aujourd'hui
considéré comme l'un des plus beaux en
france sa piste en herbe fait 1800
mètres avec une corde à gauche
sa largeur et 2 50 mètres ce dimanche 20
juin l'enceinte sportif est encore
l'unanimité auprès des drivers et hop
y a rien à dire fanny top c'est une
excellente piste il n'y a pas de piège
c'est souvent le meilleur cheval qui
gagne donc voilà les jeux super bien
entretenue chez des grands virages des
grandes heures de départ non c'est le
top
on a aussi bien installé qu'à vincennes
en dehors des courses l'hippodrome de
rambouillet se veut également être un
lieu de vie à chaque réunion des
centaines de personnes peuvent
participer à des animations autour de
l'équitation organisé par les trois
bénévoles du site
une grande salle de paris de 300 m² est
ouverte pendant la manifestation les
visiteurs peuvent en parallèle approcher
au plus près les professionnels et les
115 chevaux présents à chaque rendez
vous je pense que même les plus petits
sont très contents de regarder les
chevaux en plus ici sur l'hippodrome de
rambouillet le chaque personne peut
aller se balader dans les stalles aller
rencontrer les chevaux aller les voir
prendre leur douche aller parler aux
propriétaires et poser toutes les
questions qu'ils veulent
le seul endroit où et on ne peut pas
marcher c'est sur la piste en selle pour
le spectacle les prochaines courses à
rambouillet sont programmées en
septembre sur l'hippodrome
c'est déjà la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite une très
belle soirée
[Musique]